today we're talking about eldon ring
preloading and file size as well as some
new reports on call of duty and halo and
battlefield
mistakes were made
with elden ring less than a week away
you're probably wondering how much space
you'll need to clear out on your
platform of choice pre-loading elden
ring is possible for all players who
pre-ordered the game and is currently
live for xbox players because of this we
know the file size for xbox consoles is
49.04 gigabytes though this may increase
if a separate day one patch is required
the file size on playstation is reported
to be
44.929 gigabytes according to a twitter
account called playstation game size
adding to this there's no confirmation
of a file size for the pc version of the
game yet either though the recently
released pc requirements for eldon ring
requires players to have at least 60
gigs of free space however similar to
xbox the sizes on both of these
platforms can change if a day 1 patch is
required it's also important to note
that a preload date for playstation and
pc have not been announced
switching gears to some shooter news
electronic arts has openly admitted that
battlefield 2042 failed to meet its
sales expectations and a recent report
said that the launch of halo infinite
might have contributed to lower than
expected results and even though it
might have played a role ea has now
reacted to that report saying it is
quote not blaming external factors for
battlefield 2042's underperformance
relative to ea's expectations for those
just catching up xfire reported this
week that ea held a town hall meeting
recently during which it discussed what
happened with battlefield 2042 the
report listed many reasons for why
battlefield might have come up short but
much of the discussion surrounding the
piece was focused on what role halo
infinite's launch around the same time
might have had on the game fans may
recall that microsoft's surprise
launched halo infinite multiplayer on
november 15th just days before
battlefield 2042 launch ea
communications vice president john
riesberg told pc gamer that the stories
floating around the internet do not
accurately represent the quote
discussion and the context of the town
hall meeting reesberg said this was an
in-depth and very humble internal
conversation about battlefield 2042's
launch the xfire report which was
published by tom henderson said
battlefield 2042 might have struggled in
the market due to development issues
with its engine the work from home setup
due to covid and comparisons to other
more polished games in the market like
halo infinite but now let's talk about
battlefield's other competitor call of
duty activision has provided an update
on call of duty's anti-cheat ricochet
which was launched in 2021 amid
complaints that warzone had been overrun
with cheaters in a blog post activision
said cheating within warzone reached an
all-time low during the holidays
speaking to the success of ricochet's
tools however fighting cheaters is a
never-ending project and activision
acknowledged this in its statement the
company also said it has released a new
feature called damage shield which can
identify cheating in real time and
prevent the player from doing critical
damage to other players this system will
never impact law abiding players damage
shield is one of many new features that
make up ricochet and more are in
development since some of the features
rolled out in the past few weeks
activision said it saw a decline in
cheating reports activision also teased
what sounds like potentially more
outlandish or unexpected cheating
mitigation efforts
it said quote you might start seeing
clips of our new tricks soon but we
won't ruin the surprise the company said
it wants to share as much detail as it
can regarding anti-qi projects but it
can't and won't always do this so as to
not give cheaters a heads up but all
right it's friday let me know if you're
playing horizon forbidden west this
weekend or if you're just watching the
elden ring trailers on loop i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you